marine le pen dit zemmour ne se bat pas
pour gagner mais pour tuer le
rassemblement national vous vous dites
cyr exe moore a pu émerger c'est parce
que marine le pen lui a laissé l'espace
nécessaire qu'est ce que vous voulez
dire par là maintenant vous êtes de mon
mari nos peines on va mettre les dix
minutes alors tout d'abord je vais
saluer marine le pen c'est durant
laquelle j'ai eu toujours d'admiration à
ce que vous avez porté été lourd à
porter donc sonné à le dire est par
ailleurs vous n'avez pas de ses droits
marlène ski après sa partie la sororité
dont les féministes nous bassine
volontiers vous n'avez pas beaucoup vécu
en 2017 j'ai pas vu beaucoup de
féministes appelé à voter marine le pen
pour installer une femme à l'elysée cela
étant dit depuis 2010 est un point a
changé c'est l'émergence d'eric zemmour
l'émergence d'eric zemmour et jeu
on peut se poser la question
cette dynamique militante qu'il a pu
créer est ce que elle elle n'a pas
finalement elle n'est pas due à un
espace que vous avez laissé c'est vrai
que quand on entend les cadres qui
étaient chez vous et qui sont partis je
pense par exemple à nicolas bay parle de
vos de vaud reculade vos revirements ce
sont ses mots le sur hull à la sortie de
la cndh
elle à la fema la binationalité la
sortie de schengen il développe comme ça
un certain nombre de points est ce que
en avec ses renoncements vous n'avez pas
créé un espace pour éric démon avec
gabriel pardon mais et donc il rejoint
un candidat qui est pour la pma qui est
contre la double l'interdiction de la
double nationalité et qui lui-même a
fait un recours à la cee d âge
d'ailleurs après la sa condamnation
devant les tribunaux donc je pense que
quand on veut encore une fois ça
débarrasse et son chien on l'accuse de
la rage et je pense que tout ça n'est
pas très sérieux pourquoi parce que moi
j'ai un objectif mon objectif n'a jamais
changé les moyens pour y parvenir
parfois effectivement ont évolué parce
que j'essaye de trouver le chemin le
plus efficace le plus performant et sûr
la cdh c'est exactement ce que j'ai fait
au départ je me disais bon on peut pas à
régler le problème de l'immigration avec
les règles de la cour européenne des
droits de l'homme donc bah il faut en
sortir et puis à force de travailler
avec nos juristes avec nos conseillers
d'état eh bien nous avons mis en oeuvre
dans le référendum justement cette
supériorité de la constitution française
sur les règles internationales ça veut
dire qu'on peut aujourd'hui maîtriser
l'immigration s'en sortir de la cod h et
tant mieux parce que dans la cee d âge
c'est aussi des protections des droits
fondamentaux et voyez même eric zemmour
arrive à aller se tourner vers la cod
âge qui considère que les tribunaux de
son propre pays ou peut-être demain le
gouvernement de son propre pays viole
ses droits fondamentaux donc je pense
que c'est un mauvais procès en réalité
qui est fait maintenant je parle pas des
cadres qui ont pu rejoindre avec zemmour
qui parfois sont portés par une ambition
il pense avoir la base qu'ils n'ont pas
eue
ou ce qu'ils pensent de voir leur être
donné bon tout ça ça n'a pas
d'importance qui est sûr c'est qu'il ya
des électeurs qui suivent exelmans ça
c'est une certitude ses électeurs je
pense que ils sont aussi qu'on dira
séduit par une forme de de brutalité
parce qu en fait est un phénomène de
ras-le-bol l'immigration l'insécurité a
créé chez les français c'est vrai à un
phénomène de ras-le-bol et ils se disent
bon on va aller à celui qui parle le
plus dur mais celui qui parle le plus
dur n'est pas celui qui est le plus en
capacité
de véritablement eux devraient
appliquer ce qui va permettre aux
français d'être protégés de
l'immigration et de la sécurité moi je
me souviens qu'il faisait moins au début
il disait moi je me présente parce que
je suis le seul à pouvoir gagner face à
emmanuel macron bon il y à t'il et à 32%
et mais non mais tout le monde a dit ça
on vous l'avait dit aussi valérie
pécresse l'a dit aussi on est d'accord
mais non mais on peut tous dira
évidemment on va pas dire on est on est
d'accord mais il ya quand même un
certain nombre d'études d'opinion qui au
bout d'un moment quand il y en a 60 de
suite vous dise une chose eric zemmour
n'a pas la possibilité d'être au second
tour et même s'il est au second tour il
ferait 32 ou 33 % face à emmanuel macron
moi j'ai la possibilité d'être au second
tour et je suis donné entre 45 et 47 %
au second tour donc j'ai la capacité de
gagner face à emmanuel macron mais oui
mais oui mais
gabriel qu'ils aiment mais c'est juste
je suis un mental parce que c'est ça
l'objectif de la même question à vous
poser est ce qu est ce que pour vous la
l'émergence d' eric zemmour a fait que
marine le pen il ya beaucoup de gens qui
disent qu'elles ces lycées voilà que
maintenant tu sais ce que tu as cool et
l'oeuf grèce que
eric zemmour est arrivé parce que marine
le pen ces lycées ou est-ce que marine
le pen celle ci lycée voilà fait de
l'arrivée d'eric zemmour alors certains
considèrent que c'est positif d'autres
que c'est négatif moi je voudrais quand
même revenir sur sept ce départ des
cadres parce que c'est quand même on ne
peut pas l'écarter du revers de la main
ils sont tous autres ou si j'en crois
les commentaires qui sont faits sur les
réseaux sociaux y compris par vos cadres
d'une mouvance plutôt content de la
mouvance plutôt conservatrice de vos
cadres et vous qui êtes si proche de
viktor orban que répondez-vous quand ils
vous disent nous nous sommes sentis mis
à l'écart nous avons compris que tous
les sujets sociétaux c'était plus une
priorité que on revenait à une
conception extrêmement dur de la laïcité
alors que eric zemmour nous doute dit
nuit par exemple le lait le catholicisme
un droit d'aînesse dans notre pays du
fait de sa consubstantialité avec tu
avais avec la france et vous vous vous
êtes sûr sur d'autre discours que cela
donc c'est vraiment un choix quitter
pour coter pardon les conservateurs
vraiment non pas du tout ma va écouter
voilà des gens qui viennent nous dire
qu'ils ont été maltraités regardez il y
en a trois qui sont députés européens
donc j'ai mis sur des listes pour qu'il
soit élu 1 ils n'ont pas été élus de
leur propre chef ces gens là je les ai
mis sur une liste et ils ont été élus
parce que je les ai investi bon donc
c'est un peu trop facile de dire ça
maintenant je n'ai jamais
fait croire que j'étais autre chose que
ce que j'étais galerie et cluzel j'ai
moins imposer le débat sur la laïcité
dans mon propre mouvement ça fait 20 ans
et effectivement j'ai été combattue par
un certain nombre de personnes qui
considérait qu'il fallait que
en quelque sorte leur idée religieuse
devait prendre le pas sur les idées
politiques c'est vrai sauf que moi j'ai
été élu quatre fois la tête de mon
mouvement cela s'appelle la démocratie
et ils ne l'ont pas accepté je ne les ai
pas combattu je ne vais pas sanctionner
encore une fois ils ont tous des ils
avaient tous des postes extrêmement
importants y compris le premier nicolas
bay qui était quand même qui a pris ma
place comme président du groupe sont
parlés pour au bain marie nommée mais je
veux dire une chose c'est que en réalité
et ils jouent non pas 2022 mais 2027 ce
qu'ils rêvent de faire c'est une
recomposition
de la droite et ils m'en veulent parce
que moi je le redis la droite ça ne
m'intéresse pas pas plus que la gauche
ne m'interesse la seule chose qui
m'intéresse c'est la france donc je veux
réunir autour des noirs
qui considère que la france ait leurs
priorités et leurs histoires d'appareils
de tu vas voir je te donne cinq
circonscriptions tu viens que j'ai
simplement intervenir en jeu toute la
phase alors j'aimerais faire de la
droite non ce que je trouve ça
intéressant tu sois sûr c'est très
intéressant voilà justement garder les
jouer je suis posé une question après je
voulais juste c'est vrai que plein de
gens disent et qu'elle vienne pas me
contredire dise voilà il pense à la
presse et ils disent si marine le pen
père avec zemmour on a peut-être un
avenir voilà avec ce nouveau ce nouveau
parti reconquête il ya les législatives
derrière on va voir ce qui va se passer
voilà donc ils disent ils ils jouent un
peu c'est un peu voilà ils jouent leur
carrière ils disent 'voilà et ce sont
tous des carriéristes il dit on va les
criques zemmour il ya plus d'espoir à
carrick marine le pen je pense que c'est
quand même leur faire injure de les
traiter tous deux carriéristes s'est
passé pas ses passes et ses légendes et
confiance
on a le droit d'être carriériste dans la
politique cautionna loi de la russe est
passée par là
gabriel a donc pardon pardon moi je veux
bien entendre il ya des gens qui ont des
convictions etc mais des gens qui ont
des convictions et qui décide de partir
six mois avant en fait de le faire qui
contribue à saboter une campagne de
l'intérieur et qui finissent par partir
à un mois et demi d'une présidentielle
en trahissant quoi qu'on en dise leurs
électeurs leurs amis leurs collègues et
cetera permettez moi de vous dire que
quand même ça me permet je me permets de
vous dire que il ne se sent pas grandi
dans le comportement qu'ils ont eue
d'autant qu'aucun d'entre eux n'a eu ne
serait-ce que le courage de me prévenir
de son départ donc c'est pas anodin
commerce que deezer gabriel
moi je m'excuse et moi mais c'est quand
même très contradictoires passe devant
des gens qui nous disent on joue 2027 on
va faire perdre marine le pen comme ça
après il va ailleurs la recomposition
etc etc mais je croyais que la france
était en danger de mort ils nous le
disent tous les jours ils nous disent
tous les ans la france est en danger de
mort et eux ils sont en train de dire on
peut encore perdre cinq ans et bien
manger à dire aux électeurs ne peut pas
perdre alors qu'après avec vous qu'on va
revenir j'avais dû 4d
des départs moi je ne sais pas bien ce
qui s'est passé je ne connais pas assez
l'appareil du rassemblement national
pourra juger mais non moi je pense que
c'est comme dans toute entreprise comme
un directeur des ressources humaines
quand ils voient beaucoup de cadres
partir il s'interroge un départ c'est
une péripétie plusieurs salles on
commence à se poser question non je vous
mets l'incident est clos parlons à
présent du du 2ème tour parce que je
crois que c'est votre volonté c'est de
rassembler tout le monde pour le
deuxième tour le premier point est ce
que vous ne pensez pas que c'est un
petit peu contre-productif de de taper
si j'ose dire sur le clan d'eric zemmour
en disant que c'est une caricature de ce
que vous avez fait que finalement il se
décerne en caricaturant parce qu'il
faudra bien les rassembler au 2e tour
donc des gens sur lesquels on a on a
tapé ça devient un petit peu compliqué
de faire venir des ceintures et deuxième
fois que je crois qu'ils vous proposent
un débat ce qui ne serait pas bon je
vous ai entendu et je le crois je pense
que vous avez beaucoup progressé en
matière de débat ce qui ne serait pas
bon d'accepter ce débat finalement pour
tordre le cou à cette idée que eric
zemmour a immédiatement vous à la mairie
n'a pas de valeur juste réponse parce
que c'est vrai que là on a dominé mais
c'est les questions gabriel culte vous
allez répondre parce que je sais que je
me suis engagé auprès de vos équipes à
ce que vous alliez dormira minutes avant
minuit non mais je ne cadrais
excusez moi mais moi j'ai pas attaquer
un eczéma c'est lui qui m'a attaqué
extrêmement violemment et d'ailleurs il
a passé des mois à m'attaquer mois
plutôt que d'attaquer emmanuel macron en
disant que j'étais que mon électorat
était un ghetto d'ouvriers et de
chômeurs que lui il était intelligent il
lisait des livres que moi sous-entendu
j'ai été idiote parce que j'avais des
chats et j'en passe et des meilleurs
toutes ces attaques gratuites ont été
effectués moi je l' ai toujours encore
une fois combattu politiquement nous
sommes des concurrents il ya un moment
donné où je suis obligé de dire aux gens
qui nous regardent les différences qui
existent entre eric zemmour et moi et je
viens dit et je le redis il affaiblit
les idées que je que nous portons pour
lequel nous battons depuis des années en
les caricaturant et c'est pour ça je
crois que il est aujourd'hui en perte de
vitesse et les ralliements qu'il a
obtenu gavray accusent elles n'ont rien
entraîner d'autres que de continuer en
réali et sa chute dans les différents
sondages donc attention ne pas mélanger
les électeurs ce qu'ils entendent ce
qu'il souhaite et les cadres qui peuvent
décider à un moment donné pour des
raisons qu'il a l'air de rien quand une
dernière chose parce que vous vous
parlez des électeurs et vous savez sans
doute que c'est un sujet qui me qui me
touche mais vous avez dit tout à l'heure
je crois que c'était face à jean messia
il ne faut pas et je l'entends très bien
ils ne font pas meurtrir les musulmans
mais quand vous avez parler de
communautarisme catholique est ce que
vous n'avez pas meurtri les catholiques
mais il faut leur faire payer pour la
suite c'est peut-être un peu de riz
d'abord il faut meurtrir personnes nous
cela car il faut me regarde personne
faut recoudre la france parce
qu'aujourd'hui elle a été fracturée
divisé pendant cinq ans par emmanuel
macron de manière quasiment scientifique
mais je suis obligé encore une fois
d'exprimer des choses que je vois que
j'ai vécu dans mon propre mouvement et
que je vois se dérouler chez chez eric
zemmour et notamment la constitution de
groupements qui en fait défendre leurs
propres intérêts dans le cadre de cette
démarche de reconquête moi ça n'est pas
mon option moi mon option encore une
fois c'est que tout le monde tous les
français puissent se réunir autour du
projet que je porte et y compris bien
entendu demain les électeurs de l'eczéma
mais aussi les électeurs de jean luc
mélenchon pardon et les électeurs de
valérie pécresse tous ceux qui pensent
que la france il faut encore y croire
parce qu'elle a encore à apporter et en
rayonnement et en puissance et en
protection j'ose le dire en protection
puisque vous le savez c'est un sujet
essentiel de mon projet